[Musique]
c'était un pays connu pour ses peines
très dures contre les consommateurs et
les trafiquants parfois condamnés à la
peine capitale
mais depuis juin la consommation et la
vente de cannabis sont légales dans
toute la Thaïlande but officielle de
cette nouvelle loi promouvoir l'usage
médical du cannabis mais en réalité
c'est bien l'aspect récréatif qui domine
bienvenue en Thaïlande premier jour de
vacances pour ces touristes venus de
Grèce et d'Allemagne
c'est super bon et super fort Bangkok
est en train de devenir le nouveau
Amsterdam de l'Asie sauf qu'ici il n'y a
pas de limite légale à l'achat contre 5
g par jour et par personne au Pays-Bas
un virage à 180 degrés initiés par les
militaires au pouvoir déterminés à
renflouer les caisses de l'État et à
faire repartir le tourisme
c'est pour les moments coquins c'est
super bon
consommez de la marijuana dans la rue
reste interdit fumée en public et même
toujours passible de trois mois de
prison et 670 euros d'amende les abus
sont rares à l'exception de certains
touristes
le gramme coûte aujourd'hui environ 15
euros plus cher qu'auparavant mais pour
une bien meilleure qualité explique les
revendeurs qui cherchent à éduquer les
consommateurs
vous voyez les fleurs de bonne qualité
doivent être claires comme celle-ci
j'attendais ça en Thaïlande depuis des
années c'est tellement logique que ça
arrive enfin et que je puisse ouvrir mon
magasin de cannabis
si la vente au moins de 20 ans est
interdite les magasins de vérifient pas
les passeports des consommateurs
au-delà de cette industrie récréative
tolérée par les autorités il y a aussi
en Thaïlande une industrie médicale du
cannabis comme cette ferme à 250 km de
Bangkok tous les jours s'unissa vient
inspecter ses bébés 4000 plants de
cannabis mis en terre en outre cultivée
biologiquement leurs fleurs seront
récoltées dans deux mois
j'ai investi peut-être deux ou trois
millions de bahts
l'équivalent de 60000 euros cette
ancienne fonctionnaire de la santé est
devenue une business woman experte en
THC la molécule active du cannabis celle
qui déclenche ses principaux effets
la Thaïlande va devenir le pays expert
dans l'utilisation du THC du cannabis
nous allons dépasser les autres pays les
États-Unis ou le Canada
gouvernement a promis d'offrir un
million de plans aux agriculteurs afin
de raviver une culture qui existe depuis
au moins 350 ans
le roi ramassa pensait que la marijuana
pouvait guérir les maladies et donc il
avait conseillé aux paysans dans planter
dans les forêts ainsi que dans les
montagnes des provinces de l'ouest de la
Thaïlande ou dans le sud du pays toutes
ces régions où il y avait beaucoup de
paludisme
je vois des plantes cannabis mes
grands-parents mes parents consommaient
j'ai goûté et essayer ces plantes avec
eux cela nous soignait cela nous
guérissait
des coutumes des croyances non vérifiées
par la science mais répandue dans les
campagnes thaïlandaises attenant à la
plantation un hôtel luxueux dans lequel
soulissa a ouvert cette clinique ici
même le cola est à base de cannabis des
patients atteints de maladies incurables
ou bénigne allant du cancer en phase
terminale à la simple insomnie quoi que
l'huile de cannabis pourra apaiser leur
douleur en Thaïlande la publicité sur
les bienfaits supposés du cannabis n'est
pas réglementé pas d'obligation non plus
d'informer les clients des risques liés
à son usage ces traitements alternatifs
à base de feuilles et de racines c'est
ce que chercher ces dames qui a eu le
covid
votre visage est magnifique continuez à
vous détendre
pendant la pandémie je ne pouvais pas
aller à l'hôpital donc j'ai bu pendant
trois jours de l'eau bouillie avec des
feuilles de cannabis sans prendre de
médicaments j'ai pu reprendre ma vie
normale alors que mes amis qui ont eu le
covid et qui n'ont pas bu de cannabis
ils se sont sentis longtemps faibles et
fatigué
un avis qui n'est pas partagé par la
plupart des médecins
revenez nous voir ce soir j'ouvre un
sauna aux herbes médicinales
aujourd'hui en Thaïlande n'importe qui
peut cultiver du cannabis à l'image de
cette petite exploitation installée dans
une maison de Bangkok ses créateurs
n'ont eu qu'à s'inscrire sur le portail
du gouvernement pour obtenir une licence
comme plus d'un million de personnes
depuis juin
les graines viennent de Hollande
elles sont tellement bons
thaïlandaise c'est fermé
elles opérés discrètement
mais maintenant depuis la légalisation
nous n'avons plus à nous cacher
nous pouvons briller lors de nos
objectifs c'est de faire de la Thaïlande
le Pays du Cannabis en Asie
mais une partie du monde médical
s'inquiète des conséquences pour la
santé publique 1800 médecins ont signé
une pétition contre cette légalisation
il dénonce les risques de dépendance et
des effets néfastes avérés sur le
développement des adolescents
légalisé le cannabis avant la Thaïlande
comme le Canada ou certains États
américains il y a plus de régulation sur
le cannabis là-bas si vous achetez des
cigarettes il y a une photo qui explique
à quel point c'est dangereux mais pour
le cannabis il n'y a aucune régulation
ils mettent en avant simplement les
bienfaits du cannabis je suis très
inquiet
sous pression le gouvernement a déjà
annoncé un carcan législatif plus strict
pour beaucoup c'est trop tard la boîte
de Pandore est ouverte